veamos si podemos escribir tres quintos
como un número decimal te invito a que
pongas estados en el vídeo y lo intentes
ser por tu cuenta te voy a dar una ayuda
transforma esta fracción que está en
quintos a una fracción que esté en
decimos supongo que ya lo intentaste y
ahora vamos a reescribir esta fracción
como una fracción con denominador 10
primero visualicemos esto supongamos que
este es un quinto
este es un quinto déjeme darle copiar
y pegar
este es dos quintos ahí tenemos dos
quintos tres quintos
cuatro quintos y finalmente cinco
quintos aquí tenemos un entero dividido
en cinco quintos
ahora vamos a iluminar tres quintos voy
a hacerlo en magenta como está el 3 el
mismo color del 3 vamos a iluminar este
es un quinto
seguimos iluminando estos son 200 y de
una vez los extendemos a tres quintos
ahí tenemos esto que está iluminado en
magenta son tres quintos ahora cómo
podemos visualizar esto en decimos en
vez de que estén quintos en decimos para
esto dividamos este entero en decimos
como hacemos eso pues la manera más
fácil de obtener decimos es cada uno de
estos quintos lo vamos a dividir en dos
decimos hagamos eso si hacemos esto si
dividimos aquí por la mitad tendremos el
doble de partes otra manera de ver esto
es que estamos multiplicando cada una de
las partes originales por dos en vez de
tener cinco partes iguales ahora tenemos
diez partes cada parte es una décima las
tres partes que teníamos originalmente
ahora van a ser el doble vemos que aquí
tenemos el doble de partes en magenta
estamos multiplicando también el 3 por 2
nota que hemos multiplicado el numerador
y el denominador por 2 el número no se
altera pero espero que también estás
captando el concepto cada parte cada
pedazo que teníamos originalmente lo
hemos multiplicado
2 cada uno de los quintos son ahora dos
décimos podemos escribir aquí un décimo
este es otro décimo podemos seguir
escribiendo
este es un décimo este es un décimo aquí
tenemos otro décimo otro décimo uno más
otro más un décimo más y un último
décimo así es que los tres quintos
originales ahora son seis décimos
escribamos eso esto va a ser igual a 6
sobre 10 6 sobre 10 y esto porque es
interesante bueno esto lo puedes ver
literalmente como seis décimos
así es que esto lo podemos ver como
6 voy a poner lo mejor de esta manera 6
que multiplica
un décimo para poner mejor en azul seis
por un décimo seis décimos también se
puede representar como seis por un
décimo y esto lo podemos escribir como
un número decimal ubicándonos en la
posición de las décimas cuando
escribimos un decimal digamos cero punto
el lugar que se encuentra justo a la
derecha el punto es el lugar de las
décimas este de aquí es el lugar de las
unidades y este de aquí es el lugar de
las décimas y cuantas décimas tenemos
tenemos seis así es que este número lo
podemos escribir como 0.6 y ya está
déjame escribirlo acá arriba esto va a
ser igual a cero punto
66 décimas lo podemos escribir en
notación decimal como 0.6 que es igual a
6 décimas y que también equivale a tres
quintos hemos concluido